hi i'm abby and i play blimp hi i'm
alicia and i play musa
hi i'm precious and i play aisha hi i'm
elliot and i'm okay tara
hi i'm hannah and i play stella and we
are
the cast of faith the wings saga here
with buzzfeed
to take a quiz figure out which type of
fairy we are
[Music]
first things first which hogwarts house
combo
speaks to you leather door huffle door
raven puffs leather puffs leather claw
or griffin cloth i actually don't know
much about
oh get out i'm admitting it i don't know
griffin cool i'm gonna go uh ravenclaw
i see that for you liverpool you would
be in slytherin i mean we spoke
i would be in slytherin because it
sounded the best and sounded cool
i was gonna go for huffledore door
yeah that is accurate slow the door
because
i have slytherin half gryffindor i chose
slither puff because it sounds like you
know
it's a bit you know mysterious but then
a puff of
happiness okay i love that for you
um i'm i'm going i'm going raven
puff because i think i'm i'm i'm big
ravenclaw energy um
i think i'm like um hop above aesthetic
and the part of me the part of me that
is terror is a hufflepuff so i feel like
i'm i'm
putting that in as a shout out to her
really but i'm pure ravenclaw
you are so ravenclaw i feel like um i'm
not cool enough to be in slytherin
so i aspire to be in ravenclaw and
i always get gryffindor when i've taken
the quiz pick a
not so superpower the power to turn
wine into water the power to teleport
one foot
at a time the power to control the
weather on another planet
the power to turn invisible when no one
is looking at you
shout out to stella the power to stop
time for only five seconds at a time
the power to read the minds of inanimate
objects
the wine to water one sounds dreadful i
definitely don't like that
but maybe after drinking it you turn the
wine back into water so that you don't
have a hangover
that's quite smart that's quite very
smart i
wouldn't mind being invisible when no
one's looking i would say
the power to read the minds of inanimate
objects
i can imagine that you already have that
superpower though
me too i'd like the
power to teleport one foot at a time
it would save so much time i'd never be
late for the trains
i'd i'd be on the party trick it'd be
good
if you could control the weather on
other planets because the sun
dial that up dial that down perfect the
sun isn't
it isn't a planet though is it not a
planet it can be a planet
you can have that you can have that i'm
gonna do in inanimate objects too
because it'd be really interesting to
hug a cushion and they think that
it's just choose another fantastical
boss lady to join your squad
tinker bell from peter pan prudence
blackwood from chilling adventures of
sabrina
luna lovegood from harry potter willow
rosenberg from buffy the vampire slayer
margot hanson from the magicians or
sailor jupiter from sailor moon
i'm gonna go with prudence blackwood
from chilling adventures of sabrina i
think she's sick she's definitely got
the best hair
she's got the best yeah she has the best
style
and she's just a badass all round quite
opposite character to you as well so
yeah and this aesthetically it'd look
cool you know
we'd look sick yeah i would choose
prudence for sure
you have to
you get some change you have no choice
and then i could play like a different
character and try to mess her up
i'm gonna go with with most people so
far and also say poison i'm gonna go
with sailor jupiter if you couldn't live
in solaria
which fictional land would you inhabit
hogwarts from harry potter
narnia from the chronicles of narnia
westeros
from game of thrones the capital from
the hunger games
wonderland from alice's adventures in
wonderland or
wakanda from black panther who would opt
to live in the capital what a terrible
like
place i'm gonna go nadia you know
i'm gonna go narnia wakanda because
they're technologically advanced
yeah it's just where it's at it's good
vibes what can you not leave the house
without a book
airpods wallet a pen a compact mirror
or chapstick i went for a pen oh it's
practical
and i often like to write stuff down
when i see them
i always respect people when i'm like do
you have a pen and they're like yes
i really rate that i'm glad i can do
that for you i'm gonna go with airpods
because
yeah i just listen to music all the time
and that they're useful
yeah that's very you press yeah that is
very yeah
i think i'm going to go um wallet pretty
useful
i was going to go with one as well but
then i did think i actually always use
my apple pay and also i
have forgotten my wallet but remember
the book
so a book for me i'm gonna say wallet
which
fate the winx saga character would you
not want to run into
in a dark alley beatrix riven
andreas rosalind queen luna
or a burned one i would not like to run
into a burned one
uh because yeah the rest of them i i
guess i could talk out of killing me
burn one doesn't really listen to reason
one two yeah burned one i'm gonna say
queen luna because she's
intimidating i'm gonna say a burned one
because those are scary
i would take women down in an alley pick
a set of wings
angel wings butterfly wings eagle wings
victoria's secret wings buffalo wings
and red ball wings i'm gonna go with
buffalo wings
that's the easy one for me i'm gonna go
victoria's secret wings because they
look the most stylish
i'm gonna go eagle eagle i've gone
buffalo i'm gonna go with angel wings
because uh
yeah i'm going to heaven
[Music]
bloom you've got bloom you got
what i got bloom well i got
classic we've got aisha whenever ellie
and i do quizzes we always get the same
answers
you got ayesha you're grounded um and
cool-headed
at times you can be a tad bit too
cautious
but that's only because you care about
your loved ones and don't want to see
them in harm
you got musa you're too cool for school
and pique the interest of everyone you
meet at times you can be a little
in your own head but that's because you
only trust the most worthy
of people with your feelings you got
bloom
you're strong-willed tenacious and dare
i say
fiery at times you can be a little bit
stubborn
but that's only because you're an
extremely determined person who
needs to see things through to the end
they're all pretty complimentary
they would be awful if it was like
you're stella you're a dreadful lady
the first four episodes you're gonna
[Laughter]
suck
you